okay I'll Spill the Beans here just to
you okay yes he he is
he is snoke he is you no no I'm not
gonna go there because he's just you're
starting you're starting
everybody calm down good to see you back
in Star Wars
thank you so Snopes let's back it up
because snoke's death was not only
shocking but it was also like okay now
we gotta say bye to Andy Circus already
we thought you were done with Star Wars
but boom back incredible how did this
happen but also how did you decide that
you wanted to do it I mean look I I I I
was offered it and by by Tony Gilroy and
I was in two minds at first because I
thought oh my gosh there were so many
snug theories lying around and this is
just gonna be so confusing for everybody
everyone's gonna think that Kino law is
related to snoke in some way how am I
possibly going to get through and by the
way I'm telling you now he's not so I
just didn't want people to go down that
rabbit hole but the way that Tony look I
was I was a huge fan of Rogue one and
and and Tony as as a filmmaker and
Storyteller
um so I so I really loved the the part
when when he explained it to me he
talked me through it we had a long
conversation and then when I read the
script it was just like yo yeah I mean
and whatever the consequences it's great
to be back and great to be back sort of
diametrically opposed
um from from the likes of you know the
world of snoke and uh into a into the
gritty world of the gray kind of area of
Star Wars uh which has very complex and
emotionally kind of gritty characters
all the way through it and and also to
work with Diego it was such a such a
treat and an honor to do so the set for
the prison ship for darkina five was was
extraordinary and it was every bit as
big and Grand and and epic as any film
set you've ever been on it was and the
detail in it I think we've all as we all
know we've reached a time where the
boundary between Cinema and what we see
on on the TV screen is almost in
indivisible you can't you can't you
can't judge them in you judge them in
the same way and most films of course
end up streaming anyway so so it's it
just it just doesn't I mean that the
great thing is about like this as a
series is is the ability to delve into
the richness of the characters and the
complexity of the characters in in a way
that you can't do in film and that's
that's what's so exciting and a
character like Kino Loy having having a
journey over uh you know a number of
episodes is is an example of that yeah
it's an archina five not the most
terrifying location at all of Star Wars
that place scares the hell out of me
really really scary and it's not like
kind of spooky scary like a haunted
house scary it's it's scary because it's
so desensitizing and it's bright lights
and electrified metal plate floors
walking around in bare feet in a in a
prison outfit that makes you lose your
identity it sort of messes with your
head you know and this whole kind of
it's like they're
they're all of the prisoners are
desensitized because they exist on on a
diet of a punishment or reward
um you know punishment for not working
hard enough or or reward by getting
flavor in their food so it's like they
are like these there's nothing there's
nothing
sort of biologically tangible on on the
set it's just surfaces and pieces of
metal and you know Tech it was really
messy it really messed with your head
well everybody settles down right now
Kino I think at heart is a genuinely
good man who does care about about the
greater good and the welfare of of
others when he's incarcerated as he
shuts down and becomes this cold uh
toughened you know leader that that is
that has to function just to get through
the day and to get out and he just wants
to get you know get out of prison at the
end of episode nine we see him being
reignited by by the rumors that have
been floated around that perhaps they'll
never be released and Cassian has been
instrumental in helping him find his own
truth again and as he goes into the next
episode
realizing that that you know it's like
the scales have fallen from his eyes now
and it's a horrific moment of
realization that that they are never
going to be released and that they have
to do something about it and and
actually what it's the best thing
because it for him it's completely puts
himself in touch with his inner truth
and the and back to where he knows he
he's he's actually able to affect change
which is to speak up for you know the
power of the individual joining him with
a collective to change the course of the
future and that's the journey he goes on
through episode 10. I've
I'm hoping not can you say whether this
is a limited role do you think he know
Loy has a lot more to do who knows
um who know I have no idea um look I've
Loved I've Loved play playing him to
this point so I guess we'll figure out
what happens
I love it okay you already addressed
this but I and I can feel the comments
I'm gonna get for even asking but there
are theories in the depths of the
internet that Kino is Young snoke get it
out of the way is there any connection
between kinoloi and snoke okay I'll
Spill the Beans here just to you okay
yes he he is he he is snoke he is no no
I'm not gonna go there because it's just
you're start you're starting
no he's not at all let's just put that
one out of everybody's mind he's so not
I fear
I was mistaken it was just announced
that Kelly Marcel is directing Venom
three are you excited about that and was
that something that you ultimately
decided not to do I I mean I look I knew
I was always only really ever going to
go in to do Venom 2 because of of the
amount of work that I'd done on all the
projects as I'm saying that that's lined
up in in on my sleigh
um so no I I was lucky enough to be the
custodian of that of that franchise for
it for a little while and worked with my
dear friend Tom Hardy who's who was you
know so brilliant to work with and and
Kelly and I think it's a great great
move to have her direct she's so ready
for it and it is going to knock it out
of the park
um and and yeah and I and I'm I'm very
very happy to have had that experience
and and now move on to as I say onto
onto my own projects ah well one more
thing I want to ask you about you had
the chance
um to be a part of Black Panther and now
wakanda forever is coming out I'm
curious if you've had the chance to
screen it and what stands out without
working with the wonderful Chadwick
Boseman I mean I love that whole
experience you know it was just such a a
wonderful time and and Chad is just I
still find it very hard to believe that
he's not around he's such his presence
is still out there and still you know
it's really hard to think for not being
about but yeah I I mean I'm really
looking forward to seeing wakanda
forever I I know it'll that he's he'll
live on through it in some way in some
very powerful way and yeah I I I I
really Rush looking sitting down in the
cinema and being a fan and watching it
Andy thank you so much for your time
you're always so incredible to talk to I
love catching up and I'll see you on
your next Phantom project
thank you thanks lovely to see you bye
love you bye
[Music]